first of all welcome welcome to toronto
thank you uh so happy to have you here
and i want to say happy early birthday
to you sir thank you in a few days yeah
i'm pretty excited about it what did you
guys get them is it surprise yeah
so it's
such a surprise they don't have anything
that's what it is
congratulations on this film how how
long has this been in the works for you
27 years 27 years yeah i wrote it in
1995 and uh
finally get a chance for the world to
see it i've put together together an
incredible cast that i'm so excited
about i want the world to see these
people work it's amazing yes you've
talked about this being just a joy yeah
like never enjoying yourself as much as
you have on this is it what is the
combination is it because it's finally
realizing it is it because of the
beautiful people you have with you
that that's very much part of it
before it was all about the work and
making sure that i was establishing hits
with my audience that my audience wanted
to see now that i've established and
have the studio and things that are i'm
a little more comfortable i could
you know expand and do other things and
it was the timing was perfect to do
jazzman for sure yes yeah so what was it
like watching him in his elements
i mean it's a huge he started writing
this script like the year yeah yeah yeah
pretty much it has this script has
existed as long as i have waiting for
her exactly and so there's this amazing
thing of knowing that these characters
have existed in tyler's mind all this
time yeah and it's a deep honor to know
that we embody those people and to know
that he chose us to that we that he said
like yes that is my leanne that is my
bayou it's it's amazing and i to have
that trust from someone who is such a
master of the craft and someone who has
contributed contributed so much
to the culture as it is to be a part of
that legacy
is insane it's a blessing and for you
watching these people work like i
i'm a big fan of both of you before
you know before this film and so i
imagine when you're watching them there
must be a party that's like well like
when you see them work are you how do
you how do you like
keep composed and not too impressed when
you watch them oh no i don't mind
letting people know the truth i was
really really impressed every time they
did a scene that was phenomenal i'm like
oh my god that was really incredible i
was jealous of this guy because when i
wrote it 27 years ago i wanted to play
bayou
but if i had to hand it off to someone
joshua boom was the guy because he
carries him
he brings them to life in every way yes
yeah how do so when you were embodying
this character did you have that in mind
what that you knew he would he wanted to
play this i mean i knew i was aware of
that yeah you know it's not something
that lived in my mind i felt that he
trusted what i could bring to the role
so yeah just lean into that and have
some fun with it
um when did you both discover your
voices how young were you when you knew
like this is what i want to do and you
knew that you could express
uh in a way that would
be like a gift to people when they
watched you
well first of all thank you for
describing it that way
and i have to say to be totally honest i
have always known that this is what i
wanted to do i don't know what like
maybe it's just being an only child with
parents who just like are like you're
the best i don't know what it is but i
have always had this like kind of blind
faith that this is what i wanted to do
and this opportunity definitely was just
like okay i think maybe i've chosen
maybe that's just the right path
unfortunately she doesn't sing it and
she shouldn't have yeah i wish there was
something because her voice is
incredible for joshua i wanted to be a
weatherman and that
didn't pan out so you know here we are
how would you describe today
beautiful
you know that's why he couldn't be a
weatherman
this is nice outside the day that's it
no no that won't work son
though this is the characters are
fictional yeah you know the situation
that we're dealing with the story is is
something that people can uh
hit some deep yeah you can find it in
our history for sure absolutely yeah
where did the story come from
you know i was i had an opportunity at
the time i was really broke and i i
couldn't see many plays so i was
sneaking in intermission and i had a uh
august wilson's play two trains running
was running in atlanta and i had an
opportunity to meet him after him he was
really encouraging about my writing and
told me you know all these things that i
should just continue to do to tell my
stories and i went home that night and
jazz man started to pour out of me and
here we are all these years later yeah
yeah now we know that you're
um
you you never just stick to one lane
when you're making films and i read you
said that you've got a zombie movie on
the way in networks i've got some of
everything yeah i just there's a lot of
genres i want to play in and now that
that the studio's established now that
uh you know
i was able to get jasmine out of the way
now it's like whatever else do i want to
do so that's where i am
josh if you when tyler comes calling how
quickly is it a yes is it a yes before
it calls like
that's that's a two-pronged question
okay and that
when he did call i was unsure if i had
the job or not so i actually called him
back to ask if i had the job or not and
uh he said there's some stuff to work
out you know and um
it worked out thank you
and uh yeah um
i've always wanted to be in a room with
him i've always wanted to be next to him
have conversations with him you know i
grew up being his biggest fan and i
honestly i i at some point became a
harsh critic of his you know but i've
always desired for people to make space
for my artistic and personal growth and
i always said i always read the script
that comes from this man and the script
came in i was like how does anybody pass
on this how did somebody turn this
opportunity down and i was able to read
with him and he responded to the work
and his love for this project his care
like i had to i'm just grateful that he
wanted me i i think it's very
interesting that you said you just want
to be in a room with this man yeah you
know i remember reading your post uh
after sydney party passed away saying
that you when you spend time with him
you selfishly just wanted to be there to
hear the stories yeah right and so and
to gain the wisdom yes we're doing a uh
a special institution with oprah yes is
there anything that you you know
anything else that you would want to say
about sydney's influence on you as a
person as a filmmaker as a human
well listen and all of those in all of
those areas i wouldn't be the man that i
am had not seen him because me coming up
at a time where everything was you know
hip-hop and baggy clothes and and that
was cool to see sydney party standing in
all of his regalness and being a man of
class and grace one of the only men i
was seeing be that at the time that was
really inspirational to me and i could
go on and on this entire interview would
be about him i'm so excited about
oprah's doc and and uh reggie hudlin and
the whole family that did it uh the
podiate daca can't wait for the world to
see that as well
and going back to the idea of being in
the room with someone that you admire
and that you've studied
just being there with him what did you
learn even even outside of
him as a director like working with him
what did you learn just being in a room
with this man
i i learned how to be working at the
peak of my ability from the moment that
we step on set i think tyler creates an
environment where everybody is doing
their best they are doing what they do
at their best ability and so
this opportunity really challenged me to
be the most focused i'd ever been the
most in it and dropped into every scene
i had ever been in and to really trust
in in
the you know the writer and the
directors here with us and so knowing
that if we're doing the scene and it's
flowing and he's telling us that he that
it's working that it really is and
trusting that and and you know and
getting to work with such amazing
artists like just the you you just by
you know by breathing the same air you
kind of it rubs off yeah and i say grace
patience and furthering you know making
space with someone's growth i want to
circle back to the question you asked
earlier
seeing him in his element especially
when we're in savannah you know it was
it was majestic you know really you know
his stature all of it you know and i
feel like that majesty whatever that
making up a word majesticism is
i feel like it's captured in in the film
you know and i hope that people
you know latch on to that so
how you know after having this
experience you said this was just the
most joy you felt making film yeah
how do you recreate that on another
project you've asked a billion dollar
question because i've been i've been
grieving and i didn't know what it was
for the last few weeks as we get we're
getting close to the tip and i realized
it was holding this
baby this thing for all those years and
now letting it go and that hope and that
dream i had for it was one of the last
things i had in film so now it's about
recreating a new dream and a new idea
that won't take 27 years to do so so i'm
looking forward to the next thing i have
the next project in line it's also set
in 1940s in world war ii so i'm really
excited about that but nothing will mean
to me what jazz man has meant
fantastic well thank you so much for
taking the time to be here with us